shortly before House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi announced a formal impeachment
inquiry this week Hillary Clinton told
CBS Sunday morning the president's
actions need to be investigated you live
through an impeachment as first lady and
the Clinton administration what is your
view today on Donald Trump's prospects
for impeachment well my my view is that
given this latest revelation which is
such a blatant effort to use his
presidential position to advance his
personal and political interests there
should be an impeachment inquiry opened
I don't care who you're for in the
Democratic primary or whether you're a
Republican when the president of the
United States who has taken an oath to
protect and defend the Constitution uses
his position to in effect extort a
foreign government for his own political
purposes I think that is very much what
the founders worried about in high
crimes and misdemeanors former Secretary
of State who lost the 2016 presidential
election revealed why she does not think
President Trump will be reelected she
and her daughter Chelsea also discussed
their new book